- Oh God, I don't know. What
am I doing between scenes?
- [Candace] I know.
- [Andrea] Keeping this PG, by the way.
- What am I doing that's
not PG between scenes?
- Pretty much.
- [Jodie] Yea.
- [Andrea] All phone related.
- [Candace] Totally.
- [Andrea] "Running,
pooping, and knitting."
- [Candace] We like poop conversations.
- It's so true. She is on
her own planet of dance.
- The electric slide doesn't
count as a dance move.
That's not dancing.
- [Candace] I like your answer.
Cause we all laugh a lot.
Oh. Okay.
- [Andrea] Well, it's just cause
you have the most experience.
You have the oldest kids.
- [Candace] Well, this is true.
- I've gotten advice from you in the past.
- Okay, thanks. Well I think
you two are pretty great moms.
- [Jodie and Andrea] Aww.
- [Andrea] It's true. Jodie's is the most-
- [Candace] Yours is the most accurate.
We love the '90s.
- [Andrea] We had these
20 year old choreographers
teaching us the moves to The Right Stuff
and we're like, um,
that's not how it's done.
Let us tell you
how to do the New Kids on
the Block choreography,
cause we know.
- [Andrea] "None of us- he's our uncle!'
"None of us. Bob Saget."
- [Candace] "None of the above. Ew."
- [Jodie] Ew, yeah. (laughs)
- [Jodie] We're probably
the only three women
on the planet that don't.
- [Candace] You know Bob though.
- [Andrea] Don't have anything for him.